one thing that came out on my podcast
with him because i asked him there's
this misconception that like
that old people or people with that were
poor lost money at my firm
it just wasn't true like it was not true
like i ran the firm and like this was a
policy in place like
we only call rich people now it's a was
on purpose i didn't want
people that couldn't afford to lose to
lose but also
because i'm a greedy bastard like hey
you know what you know you're going to
go take money buy so
take it from those who have the most
because you're going to get the most so
i'm not trying to say i
was the greatest guy ever but i
certainly purposely steer the weir
stand clear of people that could not
afford to lose money right
all right so let's talk about that other
stuff though let's talk about the stuff
that you really it's your area
of expertise first off i'm sure that
everyone watching this has seen
wolf of wall street but for the people
that that aren't sure who
jordan belfort is give me the the minute
elevator pitch
on uh what yeah on what you've done
so you know when i was very young we
grew up in long island both of us right
i um
started a firm uh in the late 80s
um and i uncovered this niche in the
market for selling five dollar stocks to
the richest americans no one had tried
it before and i
then very shortly thereafter discovered
a way of training
salespeople so i could take average
people that really weren't great at
selling
sales and make them unbelievable at
sales those two things combined
resulted in me building what became very
quickly the largest firm in the country
back when i was still in my early to mid
20s and i was making a million bucks a
week and i was from a poor family and i
absolutely went hog wild and lived out
every adolescent fantasy
i could ever have dreamed of from you
know buying a white ferrari test roaster
because don
johnson had one in miami vice from
taking the
private jet out to la and renting out
the presidential
the beverly wilshire because richard
gere had done it in pretty woman
i went oh i went full-on there and
ultimately it started off as a beautiful
amazing thing and i lost my way and i
started manipulating some stocks
my smuggled money in switzerland clients
lost money
i went to jail and i wrote a book about
it and that book became a movie
and i got really lucky because when you
make a movie there's two things you can
have that can happen
you could like have a movie made about
you and i love danny devito but let's
just say you can get played by danny
devito
or no offense no offense no if i loved
anybody but or leonardo dicaprio
and have martin scorsese direct that
movie and i have to say
you know what they did is they they took
a book that i worked very hard on and i
was proud of but they
uh and the writer terence winter is a
brilliant guy
and um and all of us together
created what really ended up being a
very special amazing movie that
has certainly stood the test of time and
become
probably one of the biggest cult hits of
all time and and i think it will
i don't see it ending i think it's just
here to stay forever because it really
came out
no people yeah and and it's awesome this
is
what it's a who could scorsese what can
you say right
it's just perfect i mean the movie
really from start to finish
is is just perfect the speech that leo
that you give i mean is just
absolutely epic and has been memed into
a million other things
but you you mentioned you mentioned were
that we're both from long island
you're about i you were born in 62 right
am i allowed to say that right am i
allowed to say that so yeah
so you you guys you got four look pretty
good considering
all the drugs i've consumed right i mean
good lord i should be like keith
richards from the rolling stones but i
you know thank god i did pretty well you
know no no i can't see through your skin
you're doing all right
um but no you're you got 14 years on me
but we basically come
from virtually the same town and a lot
of the guys that are in
the movie that you train in effect are
are from
syosset they're from plainview it's a
lot of these these local long island
towns
you know right outside new york city and
we talked about this when i was on your
show but i'm sort of fascinated by it
it there is something about long island
that has generated
so many talented people
corrupt people comedians actors money
guys
like it's nuts i was going to say
you're like as you would i don't want to
interrupt you i was like there's
something
in the water there's something in the
water
there's something in the water like even
in my apartment building
on my floor i lived in this six story
low rent apartment building three
people on my floor went out to wall
street and built
massive firms now one of them besides he
was a good friend so he worked but
another was an independent guy named
randy pace who i
babysat for his kids he's 10 years
passed away now
he had one of the largest firms on wall
street in the 70s like so it's like
there's something it's it's and and the
scioscia
it's like the scioscia jericho
thing i was like bass i like it and i'll
tell you what i think it is i'll tell
you what i think it is
i think it is a combination of proximity
to massive wealth
yeah but not actually having massive
wealth
it's about not being so poor that it
seems out of reach
it's about having a great education so
it creates this almost aspiration like
you almost feel like
it's just there it's within your reach
you see it it's not yours
you have you're given the tools because
like i think what's really sad sometimes
is some really you know kids that grew
up with these in
bad areas they're really they have the
decks stacked against them like they
don't get a great education
um they have a lot of gang violence like
things that it's almost like they have
to really be special to make it out and
that
hopefully you know will continue to
change and get better but i think we
didn't have that like we
although we were i wasn't born rich i
this shot that
something bad had to happen for me not
to get out to the next level like there
was such a a pathway
out and i think part of it is that
stressing education for sure
was just a big thing in my area and also
there was like this mythical thing like
you go that you move out to long island
you get rich like that
is a path and i think that's part of it
you know and i think that
that that if you take those things and
it creates a sort of competition and
pathway to success that's my opinion so
so when you were when you were building
the companies and you figured out how
you could do this by sort of reaching
the rich people with something that
wasn't normally thought of
as kind of in their world what what kind
of like ethical
issues were were you having as you were
doing it like at first did you think it
was fully legit and then kind of lost
control or did you kind of know or did
you not know or like what were you
struggling with
very good questions so number one
there's there's two things and there's a
very interesting fact that that came out
on my podcast i had the fbi agent who
indicted me is a friend of mine now
wonderful guy oh man i all right i got a
little yeah he's like you should have
him on your podcast he's a great guy
yeah
and and one thing that came out on my
podcast with him because i asked him
there's this misconception that like
that old people or people that were poor
lost money at my firm
it just wasn't true like it was not true
like i ran the firm and like this was a
policy in place like
we only call rich people now it's a was
on purpose i didn't want
people that couldn't afford to lose to
lose but also
because i'm a greedy bastard like hey
you know what you know you're gonna go
take money buy so
take it from those who have the most
cause you're to get the most so i'm not
trying to say
that that was the greatest guy ever but
i certainly purposely steered a weir
stand clear of people that could not
afford to lose money right
but yet the perception was that people
that couldn't afford
lost money the fbi has been clarified
because what happened was i left the
firm i
sold the firm in 95 and after that and
before that it was very controlled
and we were basically i wouldn't listen
it wasn't like stealing it wasn't it
started off perfectly legit
and then it started to spiral out of
control but it was very contained
about 95 legit i would say now that
given what i see on wall street what i
did was 100 legitimate
like and now given what i see happening
every single day
i i used to always say i deserve to go
to jail now i don't really think so
anymore because i there's such
corruption
on wall street it's like so bad now i
really you know i say okay well i did
things wrong but it's not nearly
bankrupt greece or isolate at least so i
you know i'm not that bad a guy right
so no seriously the things that you see
now happening in maine
in the bigger firms is unbelievable but
the the big
mistake i made was this lapse of ethics
one
step at a time so i want to be clear i
did break the law
i didn't deserve to go to jail for
breaking the law although my my
perspectives changed is what i see is
comparably but it's still i don't want
to
say i didn't i did break the law it
started off perfectly legitimate
trying to make people money and then i
made some fundamental errors and i
allowed the firm to grow
too fast and i lost control of it and
then the first time i really broke the
law i was like up i'll i'll do it once
i'll never do it again
but then my line of morality got moved a
bit
so next time you know you do things good
again from then next time you step over
it's a little bit further to the right
and then back again before you know it
through these tiny almost
imperceptible steps you're doing things
you thought you'd never do
you're associated with people you never
thought you'd associate with and it
all seems perfectly okay it's like you
dip your toe into a bathtub piping hot
water
oh wow so hot right and then three
minutes later
you're in the water and it feels fine
now when i was a young
boy i remember distinguishing oh i know
what's going on
i get in the bath and i'm the water's
cooling down because my body's cool
but no the water's not cooling down
you're just getting used to it
yeah and that was the mistake i made and
it's a mistake i'm very aware of today
like
i won't even take one little step
over the ethical line like i am real i'm
more careful than anybody else
because i can't afford to have a second
hiccup here right
so i i always say to myself like any
action i take
like if it's even the slightest bit i
think i just won't do it you know i'm
not gonna take that chance
that's my best protection against ever
doing anything wrong again
and i think it's really good for
everyone to look that way but there are
some things in life where there's gray
areas and there's nothing wrong with
playing in the gray you know what i'm
saying but you know i think that the
test is if you're going to hurt someone
else along the way that's probably the
the single thing that that's like if you
hurt someone else
if it's a victimless in the gray okay
well you can consider it but
other than that it's a no-go if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell